here we go Samantha Samantha okay you
know you should really take notes after
Madison she's a [ __ ] Madison's a
goddess
hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm your
Madison baby we're gonna check out from
twisted tens um oh I forgot the guy's
name whatever you guys know ten chilling
photos with disturbing backstories huh
so here we go perfect Halloween is
coming up Halloween it's October
let's enjoy twisted tents is not a
serious to the faint of heart it may
scare or disturb you the world's a very
bizarre place nothing's off-limits
if you decide to continue we hope as we
know from last episode there's a story
behind every photo and while most of the
time it's a pleasant story sometimes not
so much
watch out
Rob died that's his name
a class picture a great time for
students to express themselves sometimes
inappropriately Columbine High School
was your pretty average school in 1999
but also within that same year it would
go down in history as being a landmark
for one of the worst tragedies America
would come to know in this class photo
almost like a warning to students can be
seen in the upper left-hand corner
sitting beside one another appearing as
if they're aiming imaginary guns at the
camera no students have been known to do
such things this instance was far more
morbid as these two students Eric Harris
and Dylan Klebold would weeks later
initiate a massacre in that very high
school that would leave 15 people dead
including themselves I found calm down
imagine being kept prisoner by your own
family that's exactly what happened to
blob mommy egg this photo was taken
after she was discovered locked away in
a room by her own family Bloch wanted to
marry a man that her family did not
approve of and when blunt refused to see
her mother's reasoning she was locked
away in a room for nearly 25 years but
she was found she was surrounded by
excrement pieces of food and other
putrid wastes she weighed only 55 pounds
though she was rescued she never
regained her sanity and around 12 years
after being released she died in a
psychiatric hospital that is so sad
the vomitings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
were terrible events and they left
behind haunting reminders one of which
being the shadows this photo displays
the shadow of a person who was on this
set of steps when one of the atomic
bombs was detonated the bright blasts
from the bomb would be blocked by a
human body just long enough to leave a
noticeable color difference as the blast
bleached everything around the victim
leaving what are seen as permanent
shadows of a person's final moment alive
these are really I just don't usually
expect to find something creepy in a
family photo but what we find creepy and
disturbing today wasn't all too uncommon
at one time for family photos this photo
was taken of two parents with their
daughter getting a person in clear focus
wasn't easy back then as the cameras
were much slower and required you to
remain perfectly still for a period of
time though the parents are a bit blurry
the daughter is clear as can be that was
because she didn't move at all because
she had died earlier that day in these
times it wasn't an odd idea to take
photos with deceased loved ones before
they were buried making it appear as if
they were still alive for one more photo
opportunity Jesus Martis are often held
for celebrations or just generally to
have a good time the circumstances for
this one however were inappropriate at
best this is a photo taken of two
friends together Tyler have way on the
right was hosting the party where the
photo was taken shortly after this photo
was taken
Tyler began bragging about murdering his
parents friends found this odd but it
was discovered that Tyler wasn't lying
he had beaten his parents to death with
a hammer and their bloodied bodies were
laid out upstairs luckily his friends
tipped police and Tyler was arrested
Pauline space exploration is risky
especially with a low budget and in the
1960s this is a photo taken of cosmonaut
Vladimir Komarov who was assigned to an
Earth orbiting mission by the Soviet
Union however upon inspection of the
craft he was to orbit the Earth in
Vladimir knew it was unsafe with
countless structural problems he knew to
go into space with it would mean certain
death though he tried to tell others of
this issue the chain of command stopped
very much short of where it needed to go
to make adequate changes the proper
money and care just worked in place but
Vladimir went aboard the craft anyway to
spare a good friend who would have been
his replacement from dying instead this
is another photo of Vladimir after the
shoddy spacecraft plummeted to earth and
scorched him alive it was reported that
as he was falling and burning he cursed
the ones who allowed the mission to go
on for killing him the picture has been
slightly blurred as the original is
graphic but easily found on a web search
at Webster session a person can go
missing for a variety of reasons and
sometimes the clues left behind can be
chilling this is a photo of a teenage
girl of a young boy which was found in a
parking lot in Florida though the boy's
identity isn't known the girl is
believed to be Tara calico who went
missing while on a bike ride near her
home in New Mexico this is the last bit
of possible evidence ever found in
regards to what happened to Tara if you
would like to learn more about Tara's
disappearance as well as more haunting
disappearances you can click on screen
now or go down into the description
below for a link to my episode on
unexplained disappearances our next
photo is a bit disturbing for two
reasons this is a photo of a young child
in Sudan starving to death
the photographer Kevin Carter was told
not to touch or assist the children for
fear of transmitting disease as Kevin
compared to
take the photo a vulture landed in the
background a morbid sight as the vulture
was waiting for its next meal to die
Kevin Carter's photograph won the
Pulitzer Prize and because of this and
other memories of suffering
Kevin committed suicide three months
later oh my god
every now and again death isn't just
scary it's breathtaking this is a photo
of Evelyn McHale appearing as though she
is resting clutching her necklace ankles
crossed while she dreams but the truth
is moments before she stood at the 86th
floor observation deck of the Empire
State Building in New York City she
wrote a letter claiming that an unknown
man was better off without her and that
she wouldn't make a good wife for
anybody she jumped shortly thereafter
and landed as can be seen in the photo
on a limousine
not much other than the tragedy is known
about Evelyn's life when drinking it's
important to be around people that you
trust in an area that you're familiar
with the catacombs of odessa and ukraine
are vast and complicated a place where
less than reputable groups converge this
photo was taken deep inside the
catacombs on the ground lies a dead girl
who was with the group of people and
have been drinking after New Year's
festivities she separated from the group
and in her drunken stupor became lost
she wandered for three days in the
seemingly endless pitch-black tunnels
unable to see a thing or hear anything
beyond her own panicked breath and sobs
the photo scene was taken two years
after she died and rescue teams were
forced to go in and look for her
she died confused and alone that's all
for now I hope that your photos we made
positive however that's not always up to
you now is it be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss the next
episode of seriously strange
Thanks Wow why'd we end with that one
where there's like pit and race humming
hey man [ __ ] happens the one that really
bothered me was the second one dude with
the woman who was imprisoned by her
family for 25 years that 55 pound ID but
I thought it was an animation where we
were looking at at first like no I
didn't look real at all that was
terribly make sense she went to a psych
ward yeah but never recovered oh the
family photo yeah that's really creepy
cuz I was literally I was like wow our
expression is so interesting like her
trying to figure out what she's thinking
I can't believe people would do that
back then like take photos with their
dead guys it it makes sense cuz like
where you could have no take yeah you
know today I have hundreds of photos of
people I love on my phone it's so easy
see if I didn't like my kid and then he
died then I would take funny photos we
like weekend at Bernie's with my kids
yeah sure the astronaut one was very
admirable because he was the one saying
like this shit's gonna go wrong
he's not gonna work and then they were
gonna send someone else and he's like
you know what I am so aware that it's
not gonna work out this person probably
doesn't know I'm gonna go die for him
and said I don't want him to die and I
don't know what's his friend they said
yeah like he didn't want that living I
was conscious like knowing how someone
would die and he was trying to warn
everyone but he'd rather have it be him
than it it's messed up cuz you know
hundreds of people probably knew yeah
nor did a lot of people probably knew ya
can't just be this one guy who knew that
was weird the unidentified boy and the
girl that is so sad I have no idea how
to respond if I found a photo like that
that's what I was saying like what would
you do if you just saw that I feel like
I take photos like that with Veronica
but we're just messing around so right
now they they're both looking at the
camera yeah and the boy looks like he's
crying I'm gonna move on from this photo
but it's like really bothering me oh the
the one of the kid all that now that one
is probably what I'm most disturbed of
I've heard several stories of that
lately of someone who just witnessed is
something so traumatizing
that they can't get it out of their head
so they end up killing themselves you
know like it didn't directly happen to
them but they were there to see
something happen or they happen to come
across a crash you hear about that like
happening like after 9/11 or rectums is
trauma so it's like I it's like I can
understand how how you just can't get
over and you can't get it out of your
head that you feel like the only way to
do is kill yourself or it just brings
you down like a I'm not saying you
should do it I'm not supporting it I'm
just saying there's a part of me that
can get the reasoning behind why they
did sad it's just really sad that one
was crazy with the woman that fell from
the Empire State Building she probably
fell in that position yeah like she was
just she was like I'm gonna perfectly
land this Wow she look like she was like
alright I'm gonna hit that car but I'm
gonna do it as if I was sleeping is a
limo Paul Feig he had a limo and she did
it in the perfect like comfortable
position a high school way grew up next
to when I was in high school my friends
were going to it and a kid jumped off
the roof at lunch hour it was all over
the news and did he live no and so many
people were affected by it there's a
depressing this is a comedy channel what
do you expect when you watch these video
I don't know I want to make fun of
real-life deaths I guess one were the
catacombs that would freak me out for
sure I mean that sucks the body wasn't
found until two years later she wondered
for three days ago darkness how
terrified well who were her friends but
should dumbass [ __ ] apparently you
don't want to [ __ ] offer me your
friendship when friends are drinking has
gotta be soft be her supposed to watch
the drunk friends that's what I do a
Veronica for three times a week three
times a week I'm watching Veronica while
she's drinking partying flirting with
guys hitting on chicks looking at porn
I'm watching her though I'm just making
sure she's okay and safe the healthy
relationship the key to Veronica and I
our relationship is you gotta you gotta
be numb like my feelings don't matter
especially to her imagine like De Stijl
you can't ever penetrate that's the kind
of wall you got to build in front of
your heart so that nothing ever gets
through to your emotions feel like this
is hey we should talk about nope not
necessary
Veronica makes out with as many guys as
she wants if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Madison has a channel too on
chicks unhatched mm-hmm created Oh got
that lino